do you need to wear sunscreen indoors it
really depends on your situation window
glass blocks are pretty much all the uvb
so if you're indoors you only get uva
you get about 40 of uva from the sun
directly shining on you and 60 from the
sky bouncing uv onto you the uv from the
sky is proportional to the amount of sky
you can see if you're sitting in a
window then half the sky is blocked by
the building if you're in the sun you
get 40 plus 30 which is 70 of the uva if
you're in the window but in the shade
you don't get the 40 direct but you
still get 30 from the sky but this drops
as you go further into the room at a
meter away you only get 10 at 2 meters
you get 4 3 meters is 2 this drops more
if the view out your window isn't
completely blue sky so about 90 here is
blocked by trees that means my chair has
uva protection factor of over 300 and
spf infinity basically for most people
you'll want to wear sunscreen indoors if
there's sunlight directly hitting you or
if you're sitting near a big window and
you can see lots of sky otherwise you
can probably skip sunscreen